hey youtubers is Charlie so big news for
the flash season 2 in season 3 so I'm
going to talk about power girl in black
siren two completely different things
one for season two the others like a
season three thing everybody was going
crazy about Power Girl so we'll start
with Power Girl they're just talking
about super girl flash crossovers next
year in Andrew Kreisberg the showrunner
on the flash said that it's totally
possible we could see a version of
Supergirl show up on earth one that we
just haven't met yet but she would be
wearing a quote/unquote different
costume she would not have Cara's
backstory from the Supergirl TV show
there are a couple directions they could
go with that but a lot of people feel
like that's just a hat tip to Power Girl
so we'll just assume until told
otherwise that they're teasing Power
Girl and they're just going to use it as
a creative way for a two-night crossover
or even just a one way crossover
technically if they were to do Power
Girl on the flash we would still have
Supergirl from a different earth so if
you really wanted to you could have two
different versions of Supergirl on a TV
show at the same time but I don't think
they would go straight there there have
been comics where Supergirl has fought
with Power Girl
there have been comics when they fought
against each other but if you have
absolutely no idea who Power Girl is in
the comics or you haven't read the
comics she is Supergirl Kara zor-el from
a different universe so you get have
they shortened the name a little bit
just to distinguish the character it
also explains the different costume it's
one of those situations where they
created the character and then try to
weave her in with modern continuity I've
talked a little bit about crisis on
Infinite Earths that was an attempt for
DC to clean up its cannon but for the
most part Power Girl was relegated to
just society related stories so what a
coincidence the arrow the flash and all
these TV shows are doing a lot of
Justice Society things so she just she
totally works in with that but there's a
number of different ways they could
explain her on the TV show but whatever
minor adjustments they end up making
they did say that if she showed up on
earth one she would be an alien she
would be from Krypton she would still
have a version of supergirls backstory
now power girls backstory is very
similar to super girls and there are a
number of changes to explain how she got
from her universe to the main DC
Universe because her backstory is really
crazy before and after a crisis on
Infinite Earths just ignore a lot of
that nonsense expect them to use the
multiverse and the TV shows the way
they've created it just to explain that
she is the version of Supergirl that
left Krypton in the ship basically the
same backstory that Supergirl
as on her TV show with the exception of
Superman they have not explained
Superman and Batman and a lot of the
other big heroes on earth one yet so I
think the hardest part and it's not
really that hard for bringing power girl
on earth one is explaining how she got
to earth but Superman isn't there yet
where is he there and how is that going
to work because he does exist on the
Supergirl TV show we just we don't see
him that often so power girl on earth
one is actually a pretty simple
proposition it's really all the baggage
that comes with it so I'll be interested
to see how they address that because
they could say Superman is stuck in the
Phantom Zone or he hasn't made it to
earth yet he'd be of comparable age with
buried a lot of the other people so use
you'd have to explain why we haven't met
him yet here's another really cool thing
to power girl's first appearance in the
comics also featured I mean a whole
bunch of characters but amongst them Jay
Garrick in Hawkman now remember I said
that she got tied up in a lot of Justice
Society stories Hawkman and Jay Garrick
were members of the Justice Society so
that that explains why they were working
together but I think if they wanted to
do a three-night crossover they would
just substitute a couple characters for
those Justice Society characters like
it'd be Barry instead of Jay Garrick you
could substitute Hawkgirl for Hawkman
you could substitute Oliver for the Alan
Scott Green Lantern Stephen Amell was
actually joking about the idea of a
three-night crossover you know flash
arrow legends of tomorrow sometime in
the future but he was also kind of not
joking so I don't know that they would
do that next year but I think eventually
they'll get to the point where they can
do that the problem with stuff like that
is it's just a logistical nightmare it
costs a lot of money and it's really
hard to organize because for most of the
year they're almost constantly shooting
their episodes so realistically I think
what they would do is they would just do
Power Girl on the flash and they
wouldn't try to explain it on Supergirl
cannot wait to see how they make jokes
about the boob window they kind of did
that when they did the Supergirl costume
episode where you know she's kind of
figuring her costume out she comes out
with the Supergirl headband outfit she
comes out in the swimsuit version which
is like yeah I'm definitely not flying
around in this this is ridiculous
I feel like if she actually got a
costume on the flash it would look a lot
like the new 52 version of power girls
costume
minus the boob window for obvious
reasons but let me know in the comments
how do you want them to weave Power Girl
into the flash without being able to use
her in every single episode because
Melissa Benoist isn't going to go up to
Vancouver to film an episode
every single week but while you guys
think about that let's talk about black
siren which is essentially Katie Cassidy
going on the flash as a version of Black
Canary but the way they're explaining it
it's kind of timey wimey so here's the
deal the character that Katie Cassidy is
playing on the flash is not earth to
Laurel Black Canary what they're doing
is is they're kind of going the hunter
zolomon route where the same actor plays
the character it looks just like their
earth-1 counterpart but they have a
different backstory so earth-2 Katie
Cassidy is going to be called Dinah
Drake who in DC Comics history is the
mother of Black Canary her code name is
black siren now if you don't know
anything about the character don't feel
bad because she was not in the comic
books she was only in the animated
series so technically it's not canon to
DC comics but the TV shows have their
own Canon so as long as they're
internally consistent year to year I'm
totally fine with it but I know a lot of
you are asking why would they go so far
to change her name change her backstory
make her feel so different from Laurel
well I think that's part of the
explanation is that they just killed the
Laurel character and they don't want you
to feel like they're just going to bring
earth to Laurel back onto arrow because
that's not going to happen that's not
what they're doing they did say that
it's possible that in the future on
arrow someone else could pick up the
mantle of Black Canary now I'm not going
to talk too much about that in this
video because I'm going to do an arrow
video they just announced the finale so
there's a bunch of arrow specific stuff
going on that I'll talk about later but
just in the flash I feel like they want
a Katie Cassidy's character to feel like
someone who's completely different so
you don't totally associate with earth-1
Laurel so upfront they're kind of
answering the question as to why she
just doesn't go back to Earth 1 and
rejoin team arrow and everybody rides
off into the sunset together but she
will be a full-blown metahuman and it
seems like because she's been seen
attacking Cisco she's going to be a
villain which is in keeping with the
theme of Earth - metahumans earth - on
the flash is kind of like earth 3 in the
comics the crime syndicate earth where
everybody is an evil version of an earth
one hero important information though if
you guys didn't know the black siren
katie cassidy episode is flash episode
22 I don't remember if Kevin Smith said
which episode he's doing I think he's
doing episode 21 he was teasing a crazy
post-credit scene for his episode so
when we get closer to that I'll talk a
little
bit more about that but the next episode
of the flash is not next week but the
week after that on the 19th April 19th
here's where it gets a little timing why
me the next episode of arrow is until
the week after that April 27 so when the
flash comes back that week there won't
be an episode of arrow but the week
after that like the last week in April
everything will be back three nights a
week so I know it sounds kind of weird
they didn't really explain why this is
the case but I guess we can blame
basketball whatever explanation you want
to think of they just started filming
the finales of both arrow in the flash
so there's any really cool news I'll
include it in my future bonus videos but
be sure to subscribe to get everything
and actually giveaway time
congratulations to this week's giveaway
winner and Ruben Adi you win a $20
Amazon gift card be sure to private
message me on the back end of my channel
so I can get your contact details that's
just on the about page of my channel I
don't know when my arrow bonus video is
going to post but I'll start another
round of the giveaway whenever I post my
next DC related giveaway so Batman V
Superman arrow flash something like that
I can already see it now everybody's
gonna run off to write their Power Girl
fan fiction for the flash so why you
guys wait for my next video to post you
can click here for this week's arrow WTF
death episode and you can click here for
my Game of Thrones episode 1 clip they
just dropped a big scene from Game of
Thrones season 6 episode 1 thank you so
much for watching everybody let's high
five I'll see you guys tonight
Oh